- I was pretty much afraid of everything.
Afraid of the world, afraid of speaking.
You know, really, really shy kid.
So, yeah, we went to a place
that no one spoke English.
People were telling us, "You know,
"I learned English from your lyrics."
Like, oh (muted) man.
- Hello believe nation, my
name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's
major problems, so to
help you on your journey,
today we're going to
learn from the co-founder
and main songwriter from
Metallica, James Hetfield,
and my take on his top
10 rules for success.
Rule number 10 is my personal favorite,
and I'd love to know which
ones you guys like the best.
And as always, as you're
watching, if you hear something
that really resonates
with you, please leave it
in the comments below,
put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired.
You might always win a prize as well.
And also when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well, enjoy.
(upbeat music)
(hard driving rock music)
- I was pretty much afraid of everything.
Afraid of the world, afraid of speaking,
you know, really, really shy kid.
Music was a way to
speak, as simple as that.
I could either just journal, write poetry,
write just whatever was in my head
and sit down, strum a few
chords and put that together.
And that's me, that's me
telling the world about me
when I can't do it on my own.
So music was the voice I didn't have.
- I wanted to talk to you about,
there's a transition that
very successful people make,
and either they make it or they don't.
And the transition is
to go from being hungry
and filled with all this angst
to being like stupid wealthy
and famous but still
keeping your art relevant.
How do you do that?
- We're super competitive people.
We're really perfectionists and we hate
to let each other down.
There's always a better riff coming.
There's always a better album.
Maybe there's the never
satisfied part to us
that will keep us going til we die.
There's always the ultimate lyric
that's going to connect
to everyone in the world,
or something, there is
always a better something
that we haven't got yet.
- How do you stay
grounded, how do you do it?
- Well, I got a (laughs), I got a wife
that kicks my (bleep) first of all,
kids that tell it like it is.
That to me is love right
there, when your kids,
"Dad, you're being a jerk."
I love that, that's what helps me a lot.
Family certainly does that.
I think the guys in the band too,
we all keep each other in check.
"Dude, is that limo a
little too long, come on."
Just doofy things like that, you know?
We try and keep each other real.
So I think not surrounding
ourselves with yes men, too,
which can really just
totally distort your reality.
Most things in lie that are worthwhile,
you got to work at, you got to work at.
You get out what you put
in, as simple as that.
That's kind of a universal law.
So yeah, it's not pick
up the guitar and go,
"Ha ha," which I've done in
front of the mirror lots.
"Hey, I'm really good,"
and you got to have
that attitude too, but it does take work.
It does take some dedication, you know.
But if you love doing it, it's
not as hard as it could be
if you're doing something that
you're not as interested in.
- How many people have a
dream when they're kids
of being a (muted) rock star?
How many people get to be in Metallica?
- It's crazy dude, I wake
up every day and think,
"I'm friggin' blessed, I
mean this is unbelievable."
If I complain once today,
punch me in the face.
Because it's stupid, this is stupid
that I would complain about something.
But I tell ya, it is hard at times,
being on the road, doing stuff.
And you don't want to do stuff you do it,
but then you find
something, you find someone,
you find a thing, and it's
usually someone in the crowd
that's just, I see myself right there.
It's like, I'm that kid right there
at the Motorhead concert
looking up at Lemmy going,
"This is (muted) awesome!"
And so I just suck that energy and go,
"Alright, this is all I need.
"This is all I need right now."
- [Blond Man] What do you
most credit with the success,
the ongoing, the continued
success of Metallica?
If there's one thing that
is really the core of that.
- Honesty, for sure, honesty.
Whether it's in some kind of monster movie
or the music or a live show, being honest.
At the show last night,
the One intro ends,
intro to One, I go out and I
start playing Fade to Black.
It's like, what the hell?
And me realizing and getting
that wave of like shame,
like, "Oh my God, you're an idiot."
And you're like, "Alright,
just laugh at it,
"because it's kind of funny."
And what else are you going to do?
And then start the One song
and then later talk about it.
So being honest about it is so freeing,
being honest with each
other, with ourselves.
We're 53, what's it look
like, what are we going to do?
How long can we tour?
How can we stay healthy and happy?
So being honest with each other.
I think being on stage is a different hat.
It's a different mindset,
it's a different space.
It's, to me, time stops, there's no pain,
it's like when people, artists talk about
being in the zone, that is the zone.
I could get in that zone even here,
just sitting playing and
forget you guys are here.
Somehow the world goes away.
Whether that's good or bad (laughing).
It's difficult to come out of sometimes,
that's the curse of
it, but the blessing is
there is that focus and there
is that sense of purpose,
sense of being, sense of communication,
sense of creation.
That's a reason I'm here.
There's times when I haven't
played for a couple weeks
and my wife will say, "God, you're grumpy.
"Go play guitar."
It's like, "Oh yeah,"
and I'll go and I'll play
and then, "Oh, I feel better now."
It's just what it is, it's a part of me.
It's like I got to have it.
It's my coffee in the morning, too.
And it's my chill in the evening.
- Do you still get nervous
before you play a show?
- I'm nervous right now, yes.
My theory is, if you're not nervous,
then something's wrong, because
there's some intense stuff
about to happen and yeah,
there's always the
jitters before you go out.
And we have our little huddle and kind of
calm each other down and say,
"Hey, whatever happens
is supposed to happen."
We try not to take
ourselves too seriously,
but yeah, we're nervous,
because it's a big deal
and it's important.
Every little thing that
we've done in our careers,
anything that's maybe got
in our way or showed up
in our pathway we thought,
"Wow, this is great,
"this is the coolest, we've made it."
We're on tour, we have a
bus, or we have a record
or we're on someone else's big tour.
There's been so many
great little successes
along the whole way, and I'd say
after 36 years still loving
and caring for what we do
and seeing the great results from it,
it's more than any dream
that we could have dreamt
that's come true for us.
We've played in front of
half a million people.
- Half a million people?
- Yeah.
- Where was that?
- This was in Russia,
this was an airfield.
- Oh my God.
- So we've done that.
- [DJ] What the (muted) is that like?
- It was a sea of Russian people.
I mean, that's what it was.
- [DJ] That's insane to
even see that many people.
- This was in 1991, '91
when the curtain came down
and all of that, and Time Warner had a,
they wanted to basically
get their foot in the door
and so they created a free concert.
It was AC/DC, us, Pantera,
and I think maybe a local band,
or some other bands, I'm
sorry if I can't remember.
They flew us in there, we
landed in this air field,
oh, Motley Crue was on it.
Landed in this air field, and
as far as the eye could see,
I mean it was a free concert,
and it was just people.
And we get on stage and do what we do.
It was military, military in the front.
- [DJ] Jesus Christ, look
at that photo, holy (muted).
Holy (muted)m Jamie, go
full screen with that.
Just go with that one,
what in the (muted)?
Oh my God, that's insane.
- [James] Is that it, is that the one?
That might be something else.
- [Man] It looks a little
newer but it says here
it's from '91 Moscow, so.
- [James] Wow, yeah, pretty remarkable.
And there were, imagine a
sea of people like that.
And see there's a helicopter.
Helicopters flying over people.
What if that thing goes down, man?
You could be chopping
up all kinds of folks.
- [DJ] That photo, go
right up there, that one,
on stage facing those people.
Oh my God, that is (muted) insane.
- And that helicopter
would come down close
and they were yelling
at people, like, "Stop!"
People were moshing or going crazy.
They didn't know what that was.
- [DJ] Oh, they thought
it was like a fight.
- They're a friggin'
communist country, man,
and they're like, "People
are getting out of order,
"this is chaos!"
- [DJ] They didn't have
the internet then either.
- No way, they didn't know
what to expect of that.
So there are people
throwing, hitting people
from the helicopter, and
down in the front there
there were guys in uniforms.
Police, military, same thing.
So they're standing
there in their uniforms
and after like three or
four songs, they're like,
"(muted) this" and they
took off their stuff
and they're out there head
banging and having a good time.
So we saw the transformation of
a closed down society to freedom
right before us, individually
in people, it was awesome.
- Wow, what does it feel like to stand
in front of 500,000 people?
What does this sound like?
What is the sound of their roars like?
- Pretty massive, obviously.
I lost count at like, I don't know,
three hundred and something thousand.
And they don't speak your language.
That's just such a, that's
the power of music, man.
That's a language in its own.
It connects people, it is so cool.
So yeah, we went to a place
and no one spoke English.
Or people were telling us, "You know,
"I learned English from your lyrics."
Like, oh (muted) man, I failed English,
just so you know, I didn't
do so well in school.
It's pretty bizarre, yeah.
- [DJ] That's intense.
(crowd cheering and hard rock music)
(Enter Sandman by Metallica)
♫ Say your prayers, little one
♫ Don't forget, my son
♫ To include everyone
♫ I'll tuck you in, warm within
♫ Keep you safe from sin
♫ Till the Sandman comes
♫ Sleep with one eye open
♫ Gripping your pillow tight
♫ Exit light
♫ Enter night
♫ Take my hand
♫ We're off to never never land
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Fade2Gamez asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, check out
the link in the description
and you can go and cast your vote.
I also love to know which clip
resonated the most with you,
what lesson are you going
to take from this video
and immediately apply to your life
or to your business somehow.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find
out what you have to say.
I also want to give a quick shout out
to the LonelyBookaneer, thank you so much
for picking up a copy of
my book, Your One Word,
and posting the review
on your YouTube channel.
I really, really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed my book.
- [Man] In this video I'll
be talking about the book,
Your One Word by Evan Carmichael.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself, and whatever
your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.
- Me and a buddy growing up in school,
John Zanner was his name, we would,
we would try and top each other.
Every day like, "Hey,
look what I learned."
And "Oh, well look what I got."
And "Oh, damn," then I'd go
back and learn something else
and then he'd go, "Eh!", so the great
high school competition
got us to another level,
which was great, and then
at some point it was like,
"Wow, the guys I'm playing with,
"I need to play with better players."
And I was writing, I wrote some songs.
They didn't like them, they
just wanted to play covers.
And then I kind of decided,
"Well, I got to start
"playing with other people."
So right then I kind of
knew that I was on a quest
and I wanted to get better.
And some friends didn't understand that.
They just, "Why don't you
just hang out with us?"
And I was on a quest to go places.
I think it was my sophomore year,
I went back to high
school, the summertime,
to gear up to start
playing football again.
And I had long hair at that point,
and the coach said, "You
have to get a haircut."
And I said, "Yeah, but Eddie
Van Halen's got long hair
"and Michael Schenker's got long hair.
"I want to play football
and have long hair."
"You can't do it," so
right then it was one
of those forks in the road
that was pretty pivotal
in my life that I had no clue about.
And I kind of just
said, "Well, screw this.
"Do I want to be second
string playing football
"or do I want to be up
on stage with a mission,
"speaking through music?"
I didn't know it at the time
but it was pretty much the right choice.